?
>>GNORING THE A
OF MEDICAL PRESIDENT  IS N
OF ANTIMALARLTN TO TREATRUS YET.
DONS
>> Repor ACTUAL DOCTORS ARE
HEDGING THEIR NING MEDICALROOF
HYDROXYCHLOROQUINE WILL WORK AN
TESTED.
N'THAT FROM
LISTENING TO THE PRESIDENT.
>> ANSWORKN VERYG
SIGNS.te CS T
WELL-KNOWN SIDE EFFECTS OF THE
NCLUDING FATAL HEART
PROBLEMS.
>> YOU COULD LOSE YOUR LI.
IT'S >> Reporter: LAST WEEK, TH
EMERGENCY APPROVAL FOE
HOUSE' PLAN TO
MILLIONS OF TO CORONAVIRUS
PATIENTS.
ALTHOUGH NO SUBSTANTIVE
HAVE BEEN COMPLETED YET.E N'
SOMETHING AND SAY, GEE,'S PLE OF
IT OUT LET'S GO AND TEST
WITH THE TEST T LABORATORIES.
r: AT THE BRIEFING
YESTERDAING NEXT TO D ANTHO FAU
COP INFECTIOUSEASEEXPERT.
BUTHE CNN ROR ASKED
DR. FAUCI FOR OPINION ON THE
DRUG,WAS TRUMP ENTERED
INSTEAD.
>> WHATHE EVIDENCE --
>> HE AWERED THE QUESTION
TIMES.H FOR
HAS CAUSEWHE  AND EVENED D
DR. ANDP'S TOP TR WHO DOESN'T HE
>> MQUS OF
LOOKING AT THE SCIENCE IS TT
I'MIAL SCIENTIST, I HAVE
>> Reporter: PETER NAVARRO
BR A OF TO A
WHITE HOUSE SITUATION ROOM
MEETING  SAID WAS PROOF
THDR
FAUCI PUSHED BACK,
DECISIONSD BE BASED ON
ACTUAL DATA.>> T WARD
SECOND OPINION.
>> ReporteTETO THE
IE ROOM HE
REPORTERS THIS.
>> I MAY AK DOCTORS
OUTH T IT. H
ULD C ORS, SOMETHING THAT NKEL G
DRT AMERICANSAL DOCTORS, TRUMP
THATREAT FROM THE WHITE BRIINRO.
KOURYUC
>>OSED UP 600 , SCK B
DAY SINCE MARCH 24S
OF THE STISON
ROLLOUT.EWNE FOR S THEANLOFARGO
N' BUSANCHOR JULATTERLEY.
JULIA, GU.
RE TOLD ITTOOK 72 MINUTES OAPR.
IS T TSDEMAND?
>>OT SCALE, NOT
THIS  ATH
SPEED.
THAT'S WHAT WED OVER
EYS.
THE LLREES TFE SMASTRATION DID E
YEAR.HEHE VAST.
IF YMAGINE THE OF
T IN THE PAST
LE OF  BANK OF A 25 BONOANS O
FRIDAY, T THEN HAV
THAT INFORM TOTHE SMALL BUSINE.
RAO , GIVEN THEOTTALKING ABOUT,E
OF
FORLL OF
JAY GOO
YOPOKEHI
THE BANKING ASSOCIATI T THE OFH
SAYS THE MONEY WIL FLOW BY
WEDNDAY OF T WEEK.
TAPP OUT, CITIBAN
HADLE UPLO TO THE ON
IF THIS IS THEUATIONORS,
HOWHEYO DO
>>AM ISSUE, ARY HE
LOANS THE SINABILITY TO THEORRO
THREE  ONLYMOCOUL ADDG
RM TO THE WEBSE.EY ASKEDORUNDREO
EX FSIZE HEARDKEWELL IS THE WEBN
UPLO INFORMATIO
I OU AN  VE'RE SO MUCDECHNOLOGY
RATE, SHE EVES,
IS13% ANDNG TOUEOI
SHE SAIDT MIGHT
REACH DEPRESS LEVELS, WHICH
WOULD B I 20%RANGE.T ONVE YOUE
MIGHT
ST THENS S
UNTIRTH QT JANETYELLEN, FORMER .
SH SAIDT' LOOK AND
A
BUDIFF THA CANETACKBUSINESS HERA
POSSIBLE.
KEED
THIS  R GOING TO
DEPEND OHES HOWORTIVE ANDE'VE
TALKED ABOUT THE CHALLENGES FORO